- Okay, hi everyone.
My name's Alex Livingstone.
I'm a principal specialist
solutions architect
specializing in cloud operations,
and particularly observability.
I've been doing kind of operations
stuff for about 25 years.
I feel old now,
and I've been doing this stuff
in AWS for about nine years.
So I wanna start with like the reality
of enterprise observability today.
It's a lot different from
traditional monitoring.
You might have to be worrying
about having hundreds
or even maybe thousands of
accounts across multiple regions,
thousands, maybe tens of thousands,
in some cases, maybe even
hundreds of thousands
of microservices or services.
And for some of you,
you might have petabytes
of telemetry daily.
I mean, not everyone's gonna have that.
And what we're gonna talk about today
is actually it's best practices generally.
So it doesn't necessarily
have to be at huge scale.
And some of the challenges
that this leads to generally
when I speak to customers
is they have lots of different tooling.
You might have logs in one tool,
traces in another tool,
metrics in another tool,
and this becomes challenging.
Also, it can become very costly,
and it can lead to alert fatigue.
How many of you have alert
fatigue as a problem?
Yeah, quite a few of you.
And obviously, that can
lead to missed alerts
and not spotting critical issues.
So these are the daily realities,
probably for a lot of you
and for enterprise teams in general.
And when your observability doesn't scale,
you see these kind of problems:
increased meantime to resolution,
as I said, alert noise and fatigue,
data silos, and this might
not just be actual data silos,
but you might also have
team silos as well,
and that can make things more difficult.
And if your data is siloed,
that kind of reinforces your
teams being siloed as well.
And then if you've got multiple tools,
then you have to do manual
correlation across those tools.
And I see this with customers a lot.
If your metrics are in one tool
and your logs are in another,
then you have to be looking
at one tab for your metrics,
another for your logs.
You have to look at the time
and across these different tabs
and switch back and forth,
and that can be a bit of a nightmare.
And then you also have
inconsistent coverage
if you're using different tools,
different teams are using different tools,
different standards,
and that makes it even more difficult.
Now, I'm gonna come on to the cost.
Before I click next on my clicker,
how many of you here know
exactly the dollar amount
per hour for downtime for your application
or for your organization?
Anyone?
Okay, so for 90% of enterprises,
it's $300,000 an hour.
Now I'm not saying this to scare you,
and it's like it's one
to $5 million per hour,
41% of enterprises.
So yeah, this is not to scare you.
This is to help you to justify
why observability is important
to your business, your company.
So you can justify
why you should be
investing in observability.
Because if it comes at that
cost when you have downtime,
the relatively, it's not tiny,
but the relatively small amount of money
you can invest into observability
to stop this downtime happening,
the return on investment,
I mean, it should be really clear.
Obviously, as well as just the cost,
you have the lost time from engineers,
customers experience problems
that can lead to
reputational loss as well,
beyond just the actual cost of downtime.
And this can also lead
to delayed features.
There are other repercussions as well,
but delayed feature delivery
that might cause problems
with revenue that you're not yet getting.
Okay, so before we go into
the technical solutions,
I'm gonna start off by,
I'm try and get you to,
for some of you anyway,
this might not be all of you,
to fundamentally think differently
about the way you do monitoring.
So this section
is just about the way
you think about metrics.
And traditionally we kind of,
when we look at monitoring,
we look at infrastructure metrics.
So here we can see things like compute,
network, containers, storage,
and then obviously we vend metrics
for nearly all of the AWS services.
And then on top of that,
you might have your application metrics,
so performance, API calls, IOPS.
You might even have metrics
on individual features.
And then golden signals,
so latency, traffic,
errors, and saturation.
I'm sure most of you have
probably heard about these.
So let me think how to phrase this.
How many of you kind of
stop at that top layer?
Do any of you think about metrics
that may be above that layer?
Yeah, a couple of, yeah, a few hands.
And this is what I want
you to think about.
Business outcomes.
So business outcome metrics
are really, really important.
And I want you to think about this.
And there's two fundamental reasons why,
which I'll go into in a minute.
But think about,
think about what your
customers care about.
They don't care about the
CPU on your EC2 instance.
utilization of your containers.
They don't care about the,
how much storage or CPU or memory
or Lambda functions you're using.
They care about things
that matter to them,
and you should be caring about the things
that matter to your customers.
So if you go on to amazon.com for example,
our most important metric,
as you can guess, it's not
gonna be CPU utilization,
it's not even gonna be some
performance-related metric.
It's not even latency.
These things are all important,
but the most important
metric is orders per minute.
Because the idea of you
coming onto amazon.com
is you wanna buy something.
If you can't buy something,
there's a problem.
And the reason you should
measure these business outcomes,
there's two major reasons.
One is if you measure
for business outcomes,
if there's not a technical metric
telling you you've got an issue,
the business outcome metric
will definitely tell
you you've got an issue.
The other reason to do it
is if there is a technical metric
that tells you you've got an issue,
how do you know what
the business impact is?
A lot of the time,
maybe you've experienced
this issue before,
you can take a rough
estimate of what it might be.
You might have a good
idea of what it might be.
But the only way to be sure
is if you're measuring business outcomes.
So if you take, I hope you
take more than just this away,
but if you take one thing away from this,
I'd really like you to go away
and think about the
business outcome metrics
for your applications.
What matters to your
customers, measure those.
The other advantage it gives you as well
is your managers will love it
if they can see these
business outcome metrics
in near real time
rather than waiting for BI tools
and getting weekly and monthly reports.
So we're gonna go through like a blueprint
for how you can implement observability
at this kind of enterprise scale.
We'll talk about centralized logging,
how to collect metrics,
we'll talk about tracing,
and then we'll talk about
adding intelligence to that.
So we'll talk about anomaly detection.
Jared will talk about how to do,
how to look at high cardinality metrics,
and then also correlation,
and how to do that automatically
and not have to, you know,
mess around between tabs.
And then to add onto that,
we'll talk about
CloudWatch investigations,
application signals for APM,
and then some specialized
insights integration,
which I will get into later.
So now I'm gonna hand over to Jared
and he's talk about how
we do this at Amazon.
- Hey folks, my name is Jared Nance
and I'm a principal
engineer at CloudWatch.
I'm gonna talk a bit about how
we use CloudWatch internally
to monitor our own services.
But to set some context,
I wanted to take a moment
to help you understand
the scale of CloudWatch.
So every month we're processing
20 quadrillion metric observations,
13 exabytes of log data,
455 billion traces,
and we're running 861
million canaries every month.
Why is this relevant?
Well, it gives you some insights
into the scale of our own services,
and we actually use CloudWatch
to monitor these services.
At Amazon, we've largely
standardized on CloudWatch
for new workloads.
There are of course some older systems
that don't use CloudWatch
from the early days.
But most of the new ones
all depend on on CloudWatch,
and we use this across Amazon.
And the way that we approach
monitoring and observability
really starts with how
we organize our teams
and our services.
So as I'm sure a lot of you know,
Amazon follows a DevOps model
where we partition system
complexity into services
and those services are operated
by what we call two-pizza teams.
So let's start by looking at what happens
when we create a new service.
We have a set of blueprints
that we use for common architectures,
and a team can just create
an instance of a blueprint
with everything already set up.
So consider an API workload
running on Amazon API Gateway
with a Lambda function integration
that might look like this.
How do we ensure
that this system is set up
for success with CloudWatch?
Well, for all of those vended services,
the infrastructure is code templates
that we use to provision them
already configure things
like execution logging
from our Amazon API gateways
and active tracing from the gateway
and the Lambda functions.
And of course, you get all
of those vended metrics
for free from the services.
And if you're running on AWS Lambda,
it's automatically integrated
with CloudWatch logs.
But what about your custom telemetry?
And when I talk about custom telemetry,
what I'm really referring
to is the workload
or business specific instrumentation
that you need from your services.
All of the data that we need
to know what this workload is doing,
what it's interacting with,
how many records it processed in a batch,
this is all custom data that
we can add into our telemetry.
So whenever we create these blueprints,
they come pre-wired with
instrumentation frameworks.
So a basic Lambda handler like this
would also come with an
instrumentation framework
that's pre-configured the way we need it.
Whenever we create an
instrument within this function,
it interoperates with all the
other frameworks we're using
like our caching frameworks
or our web frameworks.
And so here when we create the instrument,
it'll automatically add
things like the identity
that's calling the function,
it'll link trace IDs into our logs.
And these are all things
that as a developer
I don't have to think about.
Then we can go in and we
can add our custom metrics
and the labels that we want
to include in our telemetry.
We then pass the instrument
factory to child operations
so they can continue
further instrumentation
carrying all of the context as it goes.
And interoperability
here is super important.
In Amazon, we've standardized
on our instrumentation
frameworks a long time ago,
but you can use tools like Open Telemetry
to get this kind of interoperability
so that the frameworks that you use,
whether they're caching
frameworks or web frameworks
are all emitting telemetry
in a consistent way
and carrying context as
you're adding information
into your telemetry.
When we emit telemetry,
we co-locate metrics and labels
in event data that might look like this.
This allows us to store
high cardinality context
in the spans
while using metrics for other things
like alarms and dashboards.
It also enables us to
quickly answer questions
like which requests failed
or which customers are impacted
by running logs insights queries
and contributor insights.
One of the most challenging
things in observability today
is dealing with high cardinality data.
Today, some of those challenges
with traditional monitoring systems
include that you may be emitting
millions of unique metrics,
which may hit limits on some
of the existing systems.
The insights are also buried
in that cardinality explosion.
So if you consider a service
that just wants to emit a metric latency
and it has dimensions
like customers, API
endpoints, and regions,
if I have a thousand customers
and 50 API endpoints in 10 regions,
that one metric now explodes
to 500,000 unique metric dimensions.
So contributor insights
takes a different approach.
It uses automatic top end analysis
where we take those structured logs
and we identify top contributors
for the metrics in your data.
It allows us to do real
time contributor ranking
and it's cost effective
as it doesn't result
in metric dimensionality
and cardinality explosion.
We offer a structured format for the data
called embedded metric format,
which allows this to happen automatically.
So when you emit that span data,
you have the structured
data in your CloudWatch logs
and you have the metrics
that you want extracted in your metrics
all through a single event.
And we also have alarm integrations.
So you can actually alarm when
you have a single contributor
that is breaching some
threshold for some metric.
So this allows you to identify
when just one of your
customers is having a bad day.
So this is a kind of
graph that you might get
if you're using contributor insights.
Internally, we use this for
all of our critical metrics.
We've had cases where we see
a small drop in availability
and we realize that it's all
caused by a single customer.
And we've been able to
work with those customers
to identify issues that
they may have introduced
through deployments that
may be impacting them.
We actually use contributor insights
to power the personal health dashboards
so that in a short amount of time
we can identify during a large scale event
which customers are impacted
and quickly notify you.
And this is the tool
that we use to do that.
So contributor insights allows us
to go from an aggregated metric
and identify the top
contributors for that metric.
But what if I wanna go
from an aggregate metric
to a very, very small slice?
Maybe I have one request that's failing,
maybe I wanna see the full trace
for that one aggregated metric.
So suppose I have a graph
for service availability
that looks like this.
This is an aggregated metric
and each sample in this data
may contain many
different actual requests.
And I just wanna get one of those requests
to understand what's happening.
Because we're co-locating our metrics
and our structured log
data in the same events,
we're able to run a logs insights query
that looks like this,
where I am first isolating
the data by the API
and filtering it to just
the errored requests.
And now I can get things like the trace ID
and the exception message.
But what about cross-account
and cross-region?
At AWS, we partition our
workloads across accounts
for region isolation.
So whenever I deploy a
service into a new region,
it's entirely isolated
into a different account.
But how do we get visibility
across all of these, right?
Whenever an operator gets paged in,
they know exactly which region
and therefore they know
which account to go into.
If an operator group owns
multiple service accounts,
they can create a central
monitoring account
that aggregates the CloudWatch data
across accounts and regions.
So now, let's talk a little bit
about incident detection and response
and how do we discover that
there are actually issues
that may be impacting our customers.
Whenever we create those blueprints,
they also come with predefined dashboards
that we deploy through
infrastructure as code
into CloudWatch.
This give us, and every week,
the service team will go through
and they'll review all of our
customer experience metrics
and ask questions about, you know,
what's driving this increase in latency?
And this gives us a regular
cadence to deep dive into issues
and ask questions about, you know,
whether we're monitoring the right things,
what kinds of regressions are
we seeing in our services,
and identify things that
may need automated detection
that we actually haven't configured yet.
But since we don't sit around
staring at dashboards all day,
we use alarms to notify us
when something goes wrong.
We don't want every single alarm
triggering tickets and paging operators
because large events may
actually trigger multiple issues.
So we use composite alarms
to actually interface with our teams.
So whenever a child alarm goes off,
it'll trigger a composite alarm
and that composite alarm
will create a ticket
in our incident management system.
When that ticket gets cut,
we automatically trigger a
CloudWatch investigation.
So the CloudWatch investigation
will initiate an investigation
that's AI driven,
it'll look to identify the root cause,
and it will hopefully do that
before the operator has even logged on
to investigate the issue.
We embed a link back to the
investigation into the ticket
so that when the operator logs on,
they go directly into the ticket
and then they're able to federate
directly into the account
that's having the issue,
review the AI summary,
and if needed, do further
manual investigation.
So with that, I'm gonna
hand it back to Alex
to talk about these
features in more detail
as well as a few others.
- Thanks, Jared.
Okay, the first thing I
want to talk about is,
and these are all things
that are gonna help you,
I'm gonna talk about
a bunch of things here
that are gonna help you
do this thing at scale.
The first thing I'm gonna talk
about is centralized logging.
Now we introduced a new feature
a couple of months ago,
and it's filled a big gap
because we've had the ability
to centralize all of your monitoring,
so your metrics and your traces,
cross-account and cross-region,
in either a single monitoring account
or multiple monitoring accounts
for quite a while now.
And the thing that was missing
was the ability to do this with logs.
And it's the thing that
customers have asked for
for a long time
and you can now do this.
So if you weren't aware,
we released this a couple of months ago
and you now have the ability
to have a free copy of your
logs in one central location.
So one account, one region,
and that means that you can then query
all of your logs from one place.
So I think this is a really big deal,
this is really exciting
'cause this now allows
you to have CloudWatch
as your central destination
for metrics, logs, and traces.
And before this, it was a
bit problematic with logs.
So this is multi-account and multi-region.
And as I said, this now allows you
to do these unified log insights queries
cross-accounts and cross-regions.
And it also means
you can have centralized
retention policies
and to manage your cost as well.
Another thing that's
difficult to do at scale
is creating alarms.
And this is something else
that was released just a few months ago
and, well, let me talk
about the challenge first.
So before this, you'd have to
create an alarm per resource.
So imagine you've got hundreds
of thousands of containers
and you want to set up an
alarm for each container.
And even if you do this
infrastructure as code,
it's still a bit of a pain
and you'd have to create
an alarm per resource.
And that would also lead to
having inconsistent thresholds.
So different teams would
set different thresholds,
and obviously it creates alarm sprawl.
You can end up with tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
maybe even millions of alarms.
And there's no centralized management.
And then when you're
looking at threshold tuning,
it's reactive and different
teams are doing different things
with their thresholds.
So this kind of creates
a nightmare scenario
where you have thousands of alarms
but no confidence
that they're actually
measuring what matters.
So with metric insights,
we've always had this SQL-like queries
for your CloudWatch metrics.
But the two things we've added recently,
one is tag-based filtering
for vended metrics.
So this means you can
use tags in the query.
And the biggest thing I think
is multi-resource alarms.
So what this allows you to do
is say you've got a
hundred thousand containers
and you want to say alert me
if the CPU on any of those
containers goes above 80%,
you don't have to create
a hundred thousand alarms,
you can create one alarm to do that.
And this obviously gives
you this central control
and it also allows you
to have a better view
across your entire state
to look at trend analysis.
So this transforms how we
can do alarm management
and manage all of these
individual resources.
And this is what it looks like.
So here we just have,
in fact it's the example I said.
So I'm looking at the
maximum memory utilization
potentially across every
single container that I have.
In my account, I don't have that many,
so there's what about 20 or so there.
But I'm able to immediately
just do one query
and I can set an alarm on
all of those containers.
How many of you here are doing tracing?
Okay, quite a few.
Maybe about a third.
Third to a half maybe.
And how many of you
are having to sample your traces for cost?
Yeah, quite a few.
So with transaction search,
it solves the problem of sampling.
So you can capture a hundred
percent of your traces
rather than sampling one to 5% may be.
This means you can do,
it also allows you to do
like real-time searching of those traces.
So we can go through millions
of traces in seconds.
You can add custom
attributes to your traces
and they'll be indexed,
optionally indexed.
And this allows you to have
this correlation without gaps.
Now, if you do sampling,
there's a problem.
Now even if you do tail
sampling, which is,
let's say I want to set up
tail sampling, which I can do,
and say I'll have a hundred
percent of my errors
and I'll sample 5% maybe
of my successful requests.
Well, even that doesn't work
because you might have
a successful request
that you want to go and have a look at
because maybe actually
technically it was successful,
but actually there was a problem
and you need to go and look at it.
And the problem is with sampling
is you either get an aggregation
of what everything looks like
or you can go and look
at individual traces
and see what some people
had issues with maybe.
But if you've got a particular issue
and it's not in your sample,
then, was gonna swear then,
then your, yeah,
your, I can't think of a good word for it,
you don't have the
chance to go and do that.
So what transaction
search allows you to do
is the ability to have every single trace
query across millions of
these traces in seconds.
You can filter by the business context.
So these are things,
maybe you'll have a customer ID,
you may have a session ID,
things like that, even feature flags.
So you can add those into your tracing.
And they correlate with logs
and metrics automatically.
You can also export this trace data
for things like machine learning analysis
and you can do this search
on up to 10,000 accounts.
So that's gonna work for
most scenarios I think.
And this is what it looks like.
So here, I've just done a search
on all of my traces
and just grouped them by status code.
So I've got accounts and by status code.
And then you'll see there's a button there
called summarize results.
And that just uses AI to
summarize the results of my query.
You can do this in log insights
as well as in transaction search.
And then it's given me a summary
telling me a bit about
which status codes I've
got and how many I've got.
So with anomaly detection,
we have anomaly detection
on all three pillars,
so metrics, logs, and traces.
With metrics, we get baselines
that take into account seasonality.
It uses the last 14 days worth of data.
We continuously adjust the model.
So if we create a new
model, that's better.
We'll replace the model.
If it's not better,
we'll keep the old model.
It supports custom metrics
and vended metrics.
And what it does is it
just identifies outliers.
And this is really useful
if you've got metrics that are repeatable,
so, you know, you have a
busy pattern during the day
and maybe it's quiet at night,
or you have a metric that keeps on rising
or one that keeps on going down,
or maybe you're going into
production for the first time
and you have no idea what the baseline
for that metric is gonna be.
So there's kind of four use cases
for using anomaly detection for metrics.
And then we've also got
anomaly detection for logs.
This is built on something we introduced,
I think it was last year,
which was pattern detection in logs.
So we've built on that
pattern detection in logs
and you can automatically
surface anomalies in logs,
just turning it on for a log group.
And there's five different anomaly types.
One is the frequency,
well, I suppose two of the frequency,
is this happening more often
or is this happening less often?
Or you might have a new
pattern that's emerged
or a pattern that's just
disappeared entirely.
And you can run this continuously
with log anomaly detection
for your log group
or you can run it as a log insights query.
Another thing you can take away
if you just take away
one log insights query,
unfortunately, I don't have it on here,
but if you do pattern app
message, pipe anomaly,
you will see it will
basically give you a summary
of all of your anomalies
in your chosen log groups
and you can choose all of the log groups.
So if you've centralized all of your logs
into one account in one region,
you could go into log insights,
write that pattern app
message, pipe anomaly,
and it would tell all your
anomalies in all of your logs
in that time period.
Really, really useful.
And then we've got traces.
So for traces, it integrates
with X-ray analytics
and it looks at things like
latency and error rates
and dependencies and
other services as well.
And I'll show you what these look like.
So this is a typical metric
that's kinda quite
steady in and repeatable.
And you can see here
everything is kind of fitting
within that gray band.
We can adjust the size of that gray band
and then you can alert on anything
that goes either above or below
or just above or just below that band.
And this is log anomaly detection
and here it's detecting an error
that I've not previously
had or an increase,
no, it's one I've not
previously had I think.
And you'll see here
that when we detect
patterns in these logs,
what we're basically doing
is looking at the patterns
and taking out the variables.
And we call these tokens,
we've got token values here,
and I've chosen to look
at these to token values
because they're showing me the trace ID.
So what I can do with this
is I can look at this log anomaly and go,
oh, okay, I wanna
investigate this a bit more
and I can actually just
look at those trace IDs
and then go and have
a look at those traces
and see some more about what's happened.
And because traces and
log events are correlated,
when you look at the trace view,
if you looked at the trace view of that,
of any of those traces,
you'd see every single log event
correlated with that trace as well.
And this is what anomaly
detection looks like in traces,
so this is in the x-ray console.
And this gives a bit
of added value as well.
It tries to give you a description
and the root cause of the issue as well.
Well, the root cause service.
And you can drill down
a bit further into this
and it gives you more information.
Okay, so application signals.
So I've said more insights, less work.
So you have to do a bit of
work here but not very much.
So before application signals
and before open telemetry I guess,
you'd have to do manual
code instrumentation.
So your developers would
have to add code to,
or your developers have to
add code to your applications,
you'd have to do manual
updates every release,
you have inconsistencies
in data collection,
which Jared talked about earlier,
and there was selective coverage as well
in what libraries were covered.
But now with application signals,
at least for Python, java, .net, no JS,
you can have automatic instrumentation.
And this uses open telemetry, right?
So this is using open standards,
we're using open telemetry to
do the auto instrumentation,
and then we're sending the traces to X-ray
and the metrics to CloudWatch.
And it's an agent based deployment.
There's no code.
It's just drop in and plug and play.
So it's just configuration.
This is particularly easy to do in EKS
because you just add an
observability add onto EKS
and then you just turn on
application signals and that's it.
There's a little bit more work to do
when you do it in ECS or EC2,
but it's basically just deploying an agent
and adding some configuration.
And it's also built into
Lamba as well as an option.
And obviously, this gives you
much faster implementation.
There's like hardly any
developer effort at all.
It's easy to maintain.
We maintain the agent for you.
In EKS, we can update the
agent for you as well.
You get standardized telemetry
across all of your applications
and this is what gives you
that full stack visibility
without any effort.
Now I would say there is one exception
where you might not want to use this
if you've got very, very
latency sensitive applications
like high frequency trading
or something like that,
you wouldn't want to use
auto instrumentation at all
from any vendor.
Doesn't matter if it's
CloudWatch or anything.
Don't use automatic instrumentation
because there is a tiny
little overhead to,
because of the way auto
instrumentation works,
it looks at the code and it
is analyzing it on the fly.
So it adds a tiny bit of latency.
But unless you're doing that,
it's kind of a no brainer to use.
And it's really hard to get a screenshot
that shows you everything
with application signals.
But this is kind of the
high level overview you get.
So it does service discovery.
It allows you to...
It creates the golden signals for you.
It allows you to create SLOs
based on those golden signals.
So you can see, I can see the
health of my services there.
So this is a weather application.
You can see I've probably
been a bit aggressive
with my SLOs.
It's actually not that bad,
but it's showing that
they're all unhealthy.
And you get services by fault rate.
And when you go into
these individual services,
you'll see things like what
dependencies they have,
what services they're interacting with
and the SLOs for that individual service.
Okay, so this is better, more insights.
No work at all.
You have to turn it on,
but that's about it.
So container insights we
can use for EKS and ECS
and it gives you resource
utilization right down,
right from the cluster level
right down to the pod level.
And it can give you metrics
on container performance,
cluster performance
information about deployments.
And it integrates with
application signals as well.
We have database insights.
Again, something you can just turn on,
well, actually it's turned on by default,
but there are two tiers to it.
And if you're running something
serious in production,
you probably want to
turn on the next tier.
By default, you'll just
get the basic tier.
So it gives you performance
monitoring for RDS,
gives you analysis of your queries,
things like connection pull tracking,
and it can also give you
performance recommendations.
So it can proactively
give you recommendations
on what you should do with your database.
And we've got Lambda Insights.
Again, you can just turn this on
and this gives you function level metrics,
things like cold start analysis,
memory and CPU utilization network.
And this integrates with tracing as well.
I'll just show you what this looks like.
So this is what Container
Insights looks like.
I've got a view of one
particular service there.
I'm just running two pods
and I can see all my metrics
for that individual service.
For database insights,
there's lots of information
database insights.
This particular database is not very busy,
but we can see the top SQL there.
And for Lambda Insights,
you can have a multi-function view
or a single function view.
Here, I've got a single function view.
This is one of my services
that goes and gets the current weather.
And we can see things like
invocations, duration,
memory utilization, CPU utilization.
We can also get a view of
the last 1,000 invocations.
We can link directly to application logs.
And there's also a link
directly to application
insights there as well.
Okay, and now,
so we've gone from doing
a little bit of work
to doing no work,
and now we're gonna let
AI do the work for you.
So we've got anomaly detection
as I've talked about across
metrics, logs, and traces.
And we can do a correlation
of all of these resources
using CloudWatch investigation.
So I'm gonna kinda show you
quickly what this looks like.
This also gives you a visual mapping
of like the causal relationships
between your services,
and it gives you root cause
analysis with natural language.
It can even recommend run books as well.
So this has a scope that
can cross multiple accounts.
So you don't have to worry
about just running it in one account.
Well, you run it in one account,
but it can take in the
scope of multiple accounts.
It can correlate with change events.
So it looks at things like,
obviously it looks at
metrics, logs, and traces,
but it looks at things
like Cloud trail as well.
As I said, it gives you
that visual overview
of the scope of your investigation.
You can share the findings
of the investigation
with your teams.
Obviously, there's
programmatic access as well.
So like Jared mentioned,
we use it internally.
We have an alarm.
We create an investigation.
You can trigger an investigation
based on the CloudWatch alarm,
and then obviously you can use the APIs
to then send that information
wherever you want.
So yes, you can integrate it
with your instance workflows.
And I suggest that if you do use this,
do it in a similar way that we do.
Integrate this with your ITSM processes.
Like if we're using
ServiceNow for example,
put this into your ServiceNow tickets.
So this is an example of what
an investigation looks like.
It's telling me what happened.
It's giving me the evidence
and the likely causes.
It's given me that visual overview.
There's some reasoning below this.
And don't worry, I'm gonna
kinda go through what I did.
So I was basically looking at this metric.
And I noticed on the left hand side,
you can see where it says impact start.
I noticed there was a bit of a increase
in the duration of my Lambda function.
That was all.
So my Lambda function was
running for nearly six seconds
instead of roughly just
under four seconds.
So I asked it to investigate.
And this is the root cause summary.
So essentially, I've...
Bedrock was throttling me because
I'd reached my rate limits
and my retry logic was failing
because of these repeated
failed calls to Bedrock.
And it was telling me my function duration
went from, you know,
four seconds to six seconds.
So it's told me the root cause
and it would tell me then
to obviously go and
increase my Bedrock limits.
So we've also got MCP
servers for CloudWatch.
We've got two of them in fact.
So we've got the CloudWatch MCP server.
So this allows you to
obviously use natural language
to go and do things
like look at metrics,
logs, and traces for you.
And we've also got application signals,
so that can look at all the
data in application signals.
So both of those working together
are probably the best way of doing it.
And these are the kind of at the top here,
the kind of natural language
things that you might ask.
And this is one of the things I did ask.
So here I am using Kiro.
And in Kiro I've got
these MTP servers set up
and I've just said my application
is deployed in eu-west-1
based on the #Codebase.
So Kiro will have
context of the #Codebase,
once I put #Codebase in,
show me CPU spikes in
production in the last hour.
Now because it's got my code base
and I've got the MCP servers,
it knows what resources to look for.
It's not gonna go and find
stuff that I don't care about
that's not related to this application.
And you can see here,
there's logging information and stuff,
but that's not really important for now.
What I wanna show you is the output.
So the output here is just showing
I had some spikes in CPU
utilization for my EC2 instances.
It said that critical spikes detected.
I would argue they're
probably not critical.
My EC2 instances spike
to like 30% maximum.
And then I've got some EKS pods,
some ECS services,
and it's given me a
kind of summary of that.
And at the end, it said the good news,
your application and
other critical services
remain stable throughout.
But all of that, it's gone and done for me
just with that one little prompt.
So this is really nice if
you're able to use MCP servers,
have a look at the CloudWatch MCP server
and the application signals MCP server.
They can be really useful
just to go and dig into things
as well as using
CloudWatch investigations.
So I wanna, we've talked about
lots of different things,
logs, metrics, traces,
these are the kind of fundamentals
before you can build up
to using those AI tools
in a meaningful way.
So you have to set the foundation,
configure a monitoring account, right?
So you've got everything in one place.
Set up log centralization again
so you've got everything in one place.
Make sure you've got retention
policies that reflect,
they've gotta reflect your
organization's requirements,
things like compliance
requirements as well.
Deploying and alerting framework,
so by that I mean the kind of
thing that Jared talked about
about when you do an alert
or when you have a CloudWatch alarm,
you know, follow a standard pattern.
Maybe it would involve
triggering a CloudWatch investigation,
opening a ticket on your system,
in the way that Jared described.
And make sure you have
tagging on your resources,
especially with the ability
for metric insights,
at least for vended metrics right now,
to be able to run queries based on tags.
That's super useful.
And another thing is,
I've not mentioned on here,
I should have mentioned
it probably on here,
is create standards.
Create standards for logs,
create standards for metrics.
Tell all of your teams
that they should be
logging in JSON format.
These are the kind of fields that we want
in every single application or service.
Things like who owns it,
what application is it part of,
what environment is it in.
All of these things are super important.
And then we come onto insights.
On the left we've got
the kind of fundamentals.
Insights, these are
really simple to deploy.
There's no reason.
Obviously, they come at the cost.
But in terms of ease of deployment,
there's no reason not to
do these container insights
just to tick.
And database insights, same thing.
Lambda insights, same thing.
Obviously, you can do this
with infrastructure as code
as well as using the console.
Have CloudWatch agents on EC2.
How many of you have
not got an agent on EC2?
Any kind of agent.
Good, that's good news.
Sometimes I speak to customers
and they've got nothing running on EC2.
Now the advantage of having
the CloudWatch agent on EC2
is obviously that gives you
everything in one place.
It also means that you
can use compute optimizer
to right size your EC2 instances as well.
If you use Compute Optimizer
and you're not using the CloudWatch agent,
then you will only get CPU
and networking metrics.
And who wants to rightsize
their EC2 instances
without taking into account memory?
Enable network monitoring.
We've got some really
nice tools in CloudWatch
to monitor networking.
I think very recently
there was something
announced with monitoring EKS
as well that's built into CloudWatch.
We haven't really had
time to talk about this
in this like short space of time.
Have a look at internet monitor.
That's a really nice thing to go
and have a look at to see
the kind of thing you can do.
And then start to look at
application performance.
If you've got applications
that are written in Python,
java, node, or .net,
then have a look at application signals.
Try it on one of your
workloads in development
and just see what it gives you
because it is very little effort
and it gives you lots of information.
If you don't wanna do sampling
and you're worried about the
cost of tracing everything,
enable transaction search.
Again, that's super useful.
It means that you're
not gonna lose any data.
Make use of application
signals for your SLOs.
But even if you are not
using application signals,
and it's not immediately obvious this,
but if you go into the CloudWatch console
and you look under application
performance monitoring
and you see SLOs,
you can actually create SLOs
on any CloudWatch metric.
It doesn't have to be related
to application signals.
You can enable real user monitoring
for your web applications
and you can create synthetic canaries.
Synthetic canaries are
really, really useful.
You can run them up to every minute
and you can either just
do like a heartbeat check
or you can run through a complex workflow
and you can run them to a schedule
or you can run them on demand.
So they might also be useful
for things like smoke testing.
So you create a bunch of smoke tests
using synthetic canaries
and you run them on demand
at the end of your pipeline.
And then add intelligence.
So use contributor insights.
Who uses contributor insights here?
Or no one?
This is really sad.
I think contributor insights
is one of the most powerful tools we have.
And I mean, I'm not
gonna go into it again,
Jared talked about it,
but have a look at contributor insights
because it's really, really powerful.
Use metric insights for your alarms.
Have a look at metric anomaly detection.
Look at log anomaly detection.
Also look at just how you
can use pattern analysis
just when you're doing
queries and log insights.
Once you've got all of this,
then you can start
to really make use of CloudWatch
investigations properly.
Now you can use CloudWatch investigations
when you haven't done all of this.
But to really get the best out
of CloudWatch investigations,
obviously like anything AI-powered,
the more information it has,
the better it's gonna be at
getting to the right answer.
You can create run books
in systems manager.
How many of you create run
books in Systems manager?
A few of you.
So when you have an alarm triggered,
you can choose to run a systems
manager automation document
if you've got something that's repeatable
and you can fix with an automation.
I think one really simple
explanation of this
is if you've got an EC2 instance,
you don't wanna get woken up
at two o'clock in the morning
just because the disc is full, right?
So there's a systems
manager automation document
already built into systems manager
where you can,
if there's an alarm for a disc space full,
you can just trigger this document,
it will expand the EBS volume,
then expand the OS volume
into the EBS volume
and then you can
investigate in the morning
when you get into work
rather than having to be woken up
at two o'clock in the morning.
We've got AWS chat bots as well.
So you can use that to send information
like to and from Slack and Teams.
It's really important to set
up these incident workflows.
Please don't be in a situation
where you just send your alarms
straight to Slack or Teams
and you don't have any proper
incident management workflow.
And then after you've done all of this,
that's when you can begin to optimize
for cost and performance.
Maybe then consider
using composite alarms.
So composite alarms allow you to create
like a tree of alarms using Boolean logic.
You can use things like
embedded metric format
and you can start to optimize
things like your log retention,
maybe also you can optimize metrics.
And also for tracing as well,
you can optimize your sampling,
especially if you are
using transaction search.
But that's it.
Thank you very much for coming.
I hope you've enjoyed your time here.
Please fill in the survey on the app.
Thank you very much.